[Aplausos]
enquanto juízes negros você já conheceu
em sua vida
quando você pensa na figura do juiz
qualquer imagem que vem à sua cabeça
seria a de um homem de meia idade com
cabelos grisalhos sério de óculos e
branco
se foi isso que vocês pensaram vocês
acertar no brasil a cada cem juízes 86
são brancos
considerando que a população brasileira
é composta em média de 53% de negras
essa é mais ou menos a forma que o
judiciário deveria ter ele deveria ter
ao menos metade da diversidade em seus
quadros mas apenas 14 juízes em cada 100
são negros
uma rápida pesquisa de imagem do google
pelo termo juiz mostrou esse resultado
confirmando o estereótipo que nós temos
em nossas mentes
porém acredito que os estereótipos eles
existem para serem desafiados eu resolvi
desafiar estereótipos
a maioria das pessoas que não me
conhecem quando descobre qual é a minha
profissão reagem com espanto
algumas dizem juíza não é possível você
parece mais uma cantora atriz e outros
desenhar mas eu imaginava que juízes era
pessoas mais velhas
eu sei que implicitamente o que passa na
cabeça de algumas dessas pessoas é é um
espanto pelo fato de ser negra no regime
democrático como que nós vivemos
todo o poder exercido pelo povo e para o
povo
isso significa que todos esses poderes
devem representar esse povo inclusive
racialmente etnicamente se fosse assim
essa seria mais ou menos a forma com que
os quadros da magistratura no brasil
deveriam ser
e qual seria a importância de ter essa
magistratura mais diversa porque nós
precisamos de um judiciário mais diverso
existe na verdade vários fatores mas eu
vou elencar os dois que eu entendo que
são mais importantes
juízes são pessoas comuns e normais no
mundo inteiro
nós em geral somos afetados por fatores
como a nossa raça gênero classe social
isso muda a forma que nós somos tratados
e resulta também na construção das
nossas crenças das nossas ideias e da
forma como como analisamos os problemas
que nos são apresentados
dessa forma o magistrado pode ter
eventualmente uma visão um pouco
restrita de alguns problemas que eles
são apresentados
isso pode ser resolvido com o uso da
empatia a empatia é a capacidade de se
colocar no lugar do outro magistrado
além de ser parcial ele deve sair fatia
no trabalho dele
a ausência de empatia implica na
impossibilidade de reconhecer as idéias
e os pensamentos e os princípios que o
outro tem se nos colocarmos no lugar do
outro nós vamos poder saber o que o
outro sente a ouvir determinadas
palavras expressões
eu acredito que é que vocês devem agora
estar se perguntando se existe realmente
um impacto
pato visível da ausência de diversidade
da magistratura
no brasil nós não temos dados
estatísticos suficientes e ambos para
que possamos fazer uma análise mais
concreta e segura
dessa forma eu vou usar o carro
americano nos estados unidos desde 1989
com a utilização da tecnologia do dna em
perícias criminais terminaram por ser
efetivamente comprovadas de forma
científica de forma incontestável o
efeito negativo da ausência de
diversidade na magistratura
com o advento dessa nova dessa nova
técnica em 1989
várias organizações não governamentais
passaram a assumir a defesa de réus já
condenados muitos apenas morte e prisão
perpétua
uma delas se chama innocence project até
hoje é responsável pela reversão da
condenação de 341 condenados que eram na
verdade nos entes comprovada com o exame
determine a foram declarados inocentes
341 condenadas 210 eram negras mais de
20 desses já estavam condenados à pena
de morte
o efeito negativo da ausência de
diversidade na magistratura também pode
ser observado na forma como alguns temas
são apreciadas no poder judiciário
um estudo mostrou que em casos de
discriminação racial empregados negros
tiveram uma taxa de vitória de 51%
quando os juízes eram brancos só que
essa taxa subiu 85% quando estes fizeram
negros não se trata
aqui de que réus negros deveriam ser
julgados por juízes negros nem
vice-versa
o juiz tem obrigação de ser imparcial
não importa a raça não importa o credo
nenhum gênero da parte envolvida no
processo que está falando aqui é que o
judiciário mais diverso vai ampliar a
visão da justiça sobre muitas questões
que podem ficar focadas e centralizadas
na visão de apenas um determinado tipo
de experiência pessoal
pensando nisso conselho nacional da
justiça desde 2015
ele implantou cotas no concurso da
magistratura aqui no brasil são 20% de
cotas reservadas para negros
imagino que essa situação deve ser
revertida nós em algum tempo podemos
contar com um judiciário mais diverso
existe um clamor por justiça eu
presenciei esse clamor diariamente no
rosto das pessoas que vêm no judiciário
sua última esperança existe um clamor
por justiça que está nas ruas está nas
redes sociais além como magistrada
só me cabe analisar os processos que lhe
são submetidos
com o uso da lei da equidade e
imparcialidade da empatia e como se eu
tivesse meus olhos com uma venda que não
me permitisse ver quem está na minha
frente para ser julgado
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]